now we start this bulletin with breaking
news an
air india express flight with 191 people
on board
has skidded off the runway while landing
in koyukou in kerala state
now media are reporting the pilot has
died more than 100 passengers are
injured
well let's now speak on the phone to our
new delhi correspondent elizabeth
peranam
liz i know this all happened less than
two hours ago details still emerging
what do we know at this stage
hi nostalgia so this is a subsidiary of
the national carrier
air india it's an air india express
flight from dubai to korea cord
as you said it skidded off the runway
during landing in karikov airport in the
city of coricord in kerala just before
8pm local time there were 191 people on
board including
six crew members and government
officials in kela have told
local media that both of the pilots on
board have died
that haven't been confirmed by the
airline yet we are hearing that
tens of people have been taken to
hospitals with injuries
we can see that the aircraft has broken
into two
pieces it's separated and the national
disaster response force are
on their way to the airport to help with
the search and rescue operation
uh there are still no international
commercial flights into india so this
flight would have been repatriating
indian nationals
from dubai and the director generalists
of the aviation has ordered an inquiry
there has been heavy monsoon rain in
kerala
all day today in fact a landslide
earlier in the day uh killed 15 people
in the district of editing with more
feared
buried under the rubble and that search
for survivors had to be called off
because of the heavy rain um liz i
as you were saying india expressed a
subsidiary of a major airline so it's a
low-cost carrier what do we know about
their safety record
well nostalgia they're we know that
they their safety they don't have um
any issues with their safety record and
as you said you know just 90 minutes
since the flights getting on the runway
uh all we know so far is that there was
very heavy rain as i was saying all day
in kerala
and so it's thought that would that the
plane
was uh skidded off the runway that the
cause was
most likely because of the weather
conditions sure and limited visibility
well we will be bringing you more on
that as we get it
elizabeth paranam there our india
correspondent thank you so much for the
latest liz